[Applause]
well if it isn't time for drew's news
your daily good news ravioli stuffed
with three types of good news cheeses
yeah and it's pasta week
i know and i definitely uh comfort eat
so this is just perfect and with me at
the desk is my trusty co-pilot rossi
ross matthew yes happy pasta week hi
everybody
all right well um this story i was
really excited about um because this new
elvis trailer is out oh my god and the
king is back and uh vogue is reporting
that we've got our first peek at the
trailer and it's directed by the
incredible baslerman who did romeo and
juliet which i think is just an absolute
masterpiece and moulin rouge and the
movie traces elvis's whole life from the
very beginning to the very end and the
king is going to be played by this young
actor his name is austin butler and he
was sort of on some nickelodeon shows
and kind of went that route of through
his life he started around 13. he beat
out all these interesting people like uh
ansel elgort and harry styles and then
tom hanks plays colonel tom parker and
he's the real life manager who sort of
plucked elvis out and really changed the
trajectory of his career
um and uh we have a little clip from it
let's take a look
i wish to promote you mr presley
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow
[Applause]
how did he beat out all those other
people oh that's why right he's so
uh-huh when the reviews come out don't
be cruel
man i should have gotten the part right
i think elvis might have been the
hottest guy i've ever seen in my life
no i don't know not in person no i never
saw him in person but like he was a
religion yeah yeah i mean people like
you know they had
everything was all this when i was
growing up and you the whole story you
think about the young elvis then in the
army and then how he sort of changed in
the vegas elvis i mean yeah that's quite
a good idea i can i get it and it's your
story well it is talking about movies
coming back to the theater the batman
finally hits theaters this friday
everybody is talking about this movie
if
you know we've seen the batman before
but this starts it all over again with
robert pattinson as batman zoe kravitz
is cat woman uh colin farrell as the
penguin and paul dana who's an actor
you're going to remember you'll know him
as the villain the riddler and this past
batman the past batman's like christian
bale they've been known for that deep
gravelly voice right mm-hmm well uh
holly i was laughing because i was
picturing myself by the way say deep
crabby voice again rossi and when i
heard it come out of me deep gravelly
voice yeah
i always make sure you're like you know
if i was upset i didn't get the role of
elvis can you imagine me as batman
well okay so i'm not the batman but
robert pattinson is and he recently
revealed that he tried a completely
different voice for the first two weeks
of filming i think he was maybe doing me
it was more of a like a whispery kind of
voice and he said it was so atrocious
that they asked him to stop they said
they said you got to do something else
so he went with something more
conventional and we actually have uh
here's a listen to robert pattinson as
the batman
what are you hiding
selena don't throw your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
justice
the answer's justice
he sounds good and early reviews i've
been reading online the early reviews
are like this is like no batman you've
ever seen before it's getting very very
good reviews who is going to go to the
movie theater and see it this weekend or
anytime
a lot
okay well i guess they made the right
call in putting it in every theater in
america then
[Music]
you